[Music]
can't believe we're having a baby you're
gonna be the best mom ever
gotta wear
this
[Music]
jackson police chief is taking questions
now on my watch i will always protect
the city and it's all for you
it's tyrone they got candice i need that
debt you owe me
what did you do to my wife
what do you want connor hey brother i
need your help
i need two million dollars by midnight
there's only one team i know that can
pull this off cap where is she
we're all watching you chief we're all
watching you show's over
everything we've done till now has been
under the cover of the flag
but this is outside the law
so what's the plan we need guns
smash and grab
business as usual
this can get ugly
[Music]
i want to see her right now you shoot
[Music]
you walk away she dies so what are we
going to do we got the element of
surprise
and we got violence you ready
[Music]
knowing what battles to fight that's
critical
[Music]
here comes cavalry made a court
you're not gonna say anything
[Music]
i know everything that goes on in these
streets
i was trained for war
i fight to win
[Music]
you